now to vanessa bryant she is in the
middle of an ongoing civil trial against
the la county sheriff's office over
leaked photos of kobe gigi and seven
other victims at the crash site it is
heartbreaking but today a moment of love
and celebration as vanessa honors kobe
on what would have been his 44th
birthday
good morning
[Music]
as the civil trial entered its third
week vanessa arrived to court monday
hand in hand with 19 year old daughter
natalia they were surrounded by
vanessa's inner circle of support sierra
and monica you have been
by her side it's an everyday struggle
having to fight everyone to even the
sheriff's office
this morning vanessa was back in court
she honored kobe's posthumous birthday
on instagram with this photo captioning
it quote happy birthday baby i love you
and miss you so much
vanessa is suing l.a county for
emotional distress and mental anguish
alleging close-up images of kobe gigi
and other victims remains were quote
passed around on at least 28 sheriff
department devices and by at least a
dozen firefighters
vanessa's attorneys have asked witnesses
to describe the photos which include
dismembered body parts in graphic detail
vanessa brian's team is saying
we don't have the photos that you
deleted purposely so we have no choice
but to go detail upon details so the
jury really understands exactly what was
contained in those photos the first
question is whether those photos should
have been taken and two who is entitled
to see those photos vanessa bryant's
team is saying no these were taken
because
people wanted
almost a prize so why would vanessa want
to re-traumatize herself by having these
details revealed in public court during
vanessa's three-hour testimony friday
she says quote i'm willing to go to hell
and back to get justice for my family
[Music]